Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala continues in
chapter number 73
verses number five
through 8
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala
indeed we are going to send down upon
you a very lofty and heavy
speech and word
indeed the rising of the night meaning
rising in prayer at night
is the most likely time
for
the heart and the tongue to be
in accordance with one another and to be
aligned. That is that when the tongue
speaks the heart is conscious of
everything that the person is reading.
He says
also
in the daytime
you have many errands to tend to and
going to and fro which is a distraction
for a person's heart
and mention the name of your Lord and
remember and recite the name of your
Lord and cut yourself off to him. This
is all of course a description
of prayer at night.
This is all expounding
upon the statement of Allah
stand in prayer
during the nighttime.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commanded the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam to stand in
prayer at night
and he gives the many reasons why the
nighttime is more favorable
for
prayer additional prayer
than the daytime.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to him,
"Stand in prayer for the duration of the
night.
Save a little
except a portion,
half of it or a little less than half or
a little more than half and recite the
Quran at a pace. Indeed, we are going to
send down upon you a very lofty and
grave and heavy word.
So this is in preparation for what the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam is
to receive of revelation
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
indeed we are going to send down upon
you a heavy word heavy in the literal
sense and also heavy in the metaphorical
sense it is heavy in the literal sense
as we mentioned yesterday
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam went through great pains and it
strained him immensely
when he received revelation of the
Quran.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam was
once asked as narrates
how does revelation come to you. He
said,
[Silence]
he said, "Sometimes I hear
an undeniable
metallic
banging that fills my ears a kind
of ringing
and
it is the most difficult type of re of
revelation to me. And once it is
concluded,
I am then able to receive and made to
memorize everything that the
messenger that the angel recites to
me meaning Gabriel.
This is
often how he would receive revelation.
It doesn't mean that it was a ringing
that was that had a rhythm to it.
It's for instance if you imagine
with me
when your ears start to ring
whether it is that you hit your head or
you hear a very very loud sound and then
the after effect is that ringing in your
ears that you get let's say after a
gunshot or after a very loud bang you
would hear this intense ringing
That is the kind of ringing that he
would hear in his ears saiam
that would drown out all other noises
around him.
And it would be of course more intense
than what we would experience of our
ears ringing.
And once that
alleviates
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
now has all of his attention focused to
what the angel recites to him.
And this is important because
when he is going about throughout his
day, he's got his own thoughts. He's got
his own ideas that he's sifting through.
He may be having a conversation. He may
be contemplating something. And suddenly
when he hears this ringing, it drowns
everything else out. And all he can hear
is this ringing, this metallic ringing.
And
that is for him to cut off all attention
to everything else and become
hyperfocused that revelation is about to
come.
And then when the angel would recite to
him whatever it is, he would his heart
was a kind of receptacle that would
receive all of this. And Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala told him when you are
receiving this revelation, don't even
move your lips. If I were to say
something to you, I say this is very
important.
I need you to memorize this word for
word
and I start saying something to you.
Most likely if you are really putting in
an effort to memorize, you will kind of
try to read with me and follow along
with your tongue and recite along with
me. You will try to kind of anticipate
what I'm going to say.
However, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
to him,
"Don't be hasty with the reception of
the Quran.
When you receive it, don't even move
your lips or tongue
in haste." What does this tell us about
the edip of the etiquette of learning?
The etiquette of learning is that one of
the great enemies of learning revelation
is haste.
It's haste that a person is hasty.
Person's in a hurry. And this happens
when a person is very excited about
learning something. They want to get
right to it. Right? You'll see this with
even physical tasks.
Many of us here have children, older
children. When they learn how to drive,
right?
You're talking to them. You're telling
them, "You got to do this, you got to do
that, don't do this, don't do that."
They're ignoring all of that. For the
most part, they're ready to just jump in
and start touching and moving and let's
go right now. Right? This is an
impediment to knowledge. Same thing with
archery. People don't want to hear about
the technicalities.
They want to get right to it. I want to
see arrows go down range or shooting or
marksmanship. This is one of the big
impediments of people learning proper
form in marksmanship.
Why? Because they're they're hasty.
They're they want to touch it and and go
with it.
So the prophet sallall.aii wasallam is
taught that that haste
is an enemy to your learning.
Do not even move your tongue when you
are first hearing the recitation and
revelation of the new verses.
Just listen. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
then said,
[Silence]
meaning upon us
is to
guarantee
that your heart will receive it and not
mistake it. And when you go to convey it
to your companions, it will be correct.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala said
[Silence]
he said indeed
we Allah referring to himself with the
royal we we are going to
teach you and you are going to remember
and not forget. Do not worry about that.
And so he would hear this metallic
ringing in his ears.
Once that is over, the angel would come
and recite to him and he would have
collected every ounce of his heart and
strength to receive the revelation.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam said,"
he said, "And sometimes the angel will
take the form of a man, and he will come
to me and speak with the words, with the
revelation, and I will be made to
remember what he recites upon me. foram.
[Silence]
He said, Aisha said, "And I have
witnessed myself that on certain days
when it is bitter cold outside,
he would receive revelation and after
this process of revelation alleviates,
I would see his forehead absolutely
pouring with sweat sai."
And this is why the companions, his
close companions,
are all the companions the same.
What' you say? Tell me.
They're not all the same.
Not all the companions are the same.
Just any hierarchy
around any man of knowledge or power, it
they're not all the same.
There are those who are the close
circle. There are those who are an outer
circle. There are those who are the
general masses. There are those who are
you know have particular functions.
Not all of them had the same exact
access to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and the same exact and the
same exact relationship with him. He had
certain companions which he was very
close with, other companions which he
was very which he was very polite
with and more
the the relationship is less deep and
more shallow. But this doesn't mean that
any of them would receive a different
message. No, they'd receive the same
message. It's just who gets the details.
Who gets the details? The closer. They
get the details. They get the secrets.
They get the hikma. And there are some
of the companions that only see him on
Juma. And there are some that are
companions that only saw him once in
their entire life. And there are other
companions that knew him for decades
before he was even a prophet.
Sallallah.aii wasallam. The companions
are different. The close companions to
him,
they knew what was expected of them when
he would receive revelation.
When he would receive revelation,
there was no speaking to him. There was
no interacting with him. He was
completely absorbed in what he was
doing. And so if he would receive
revelation suddenly,
they would
if he was laying down, they would
usually cover him up and cover his face
up and his head up with some blanket or
some piece of clothing, right? Why
Why would they cover him up? First of
all, so that he wouldn't be disturbed.
Second of all, it would appear to
someone from the outer circle that he is
asleep. But third of all, so that the
effects of revelation that he endures
are not mistaken by the ignorant.
Are not mistaken by the ignorant.
Remember the Arabs were very
superstitious people.
If they came to him and found that he
was to them seemingly incoherent
and in a state and seemed to be dazed
and sweating profusely in a cold day,
they would mistake this for what?
Mistake it for insanity. Mistake it for
possession from a demon. Mistake it for
all kinds of things. So the companions
that were his closest Abu Bakr
Abu
very later
the
Malik his servants right they would be
close to him
these companions that we all know
All of these companions that were his
very close-knit circle, they would
protect his image and protect him from
the ignorance and prying eyes.
And so
receiving revelation was not easy for
him. It was a very difficult
very difficult process that he went
through. So when Allah tells us
that indeed we are going to send down
upon you a heavy
word.
heavy here is literal or metaphorical.
Huh? Literal.
Literal or metaphorical?
Both. If you say literal, you are wrong.
If you're metaphorical, you're wrong. Or
we could say, if you say literal, you're
right. If you say metaphorical, you're
right. It is both. Because as we said
yesterday
that theul
or the hermen her hermeneutics of
understanding the Quran okay theul the
hermeneutics of understanding Quran the
functions of understanding Quran the
principles is that
the default
in understanding the Quran and sunnah is
that it is literal.
Everything is literal unless
the exception is metaphorical.
However, anytime we are able to take the
literal and metaphorical
together,
then that is what the verse intends
because literal and metaphorical they
are not mutually exclusive necessarily.
You guys know about puns?
A pun, huh? let's say for
instance,
I say to you, shoot. What's shoot mean?
Shoot means go ahead and start. Right
now, let's say I'm teaching you how to
shoot a gun. I say shoot. What does that
mean? Literally begin and metaphorically
begin. Correct? That's what we call a
pun, right?
And so when a literal and metaphorical
align themselves and both are
applicable,
both are intended in the Quran. Because
when we
exclude one of the two, we are excluding
meaning. We're excluding knowledge. And
you cannot exclude knowledge
from the Quran's words or from the
Sunnah's words without what? without
evidence.
So it's very important that anytime we
can take the literal and the
metaphorical together, that's what's
intended. Literal meaning of
metaphorical meaning
[Silence]
Quran.
Adamaz.
[Silence]
So for instance when we say
is one of
right is there only one sword of Allah
there's more there's a number of
companions three of them that were
referred to as the sword of Allah right
is one of them is this literal or
metaphorical
metaphor toal.
It means that he was, you know, Allah's
weapon against his enemies. It can't be
literal because if it were literal, he
would have to be what? He would have to
be comprised of steel and iron and
wood and stuff that. And he was a
human being, right?
It was the lion of Allah.
Literal or metaphorical?
Metaphorical.
Because if it was literal, this what a
lion literally is is you knowis
right.
Now there are instances where literal
and metaphorical both align and that is
always the best. We want to take both of
them as is the case with the names and
attributes of Allah subhanaa as is the
case with the descriptions of paradise
the descriptions of the hellfire.
These are all literal and carry in many
instances a metaphorical meaning as
well. So for instance, Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
Allah's hands are fully extended.
Fully extended in what? In generosity.
Hand here is generosity. Just I say
to you, give me a hand. What is give me
a hand. Cut your hand off and give it to
me. No. What's meant is help me. Even if
you're not going to use your hands to do
it. Correct.
However, with respect to the attributes
and names of Allah,
both are
acceptable. Imagine with me and we'll
end with this. Imagine if someone did
not have hands.
If someone did not have hands,
you know, they they had a a disability,
they are they have no hands. Would it be
appropriate for me to say give me a hand
to them?
I mean it in the metaphorical sense. Say
give me a hand.
What about if someone didn't have
couldn't speak? They were mute. Would it
be appropriate for me to say, "He's a
man of few words. He doesn't talk very
much." Would that be appropriate?
What if someone couldn't couldn't
walk? Would it be appropriate for me to
say, "I want you to run to the store for
me."
Huh? Are these things appropriate? These
are only appropriate when the literal
aligns itself with the metaphorical.
If the literal is exempt, this becomes
what?
This becomes sarcasm.
And sarcasm is a rhetorical contraption,
but it is not appropriate in the vein of
praise.
and
subhanahu